bonjour à vous tous et à vous toutes
bonjour monsieur le ministre
mesdames Messieurs les collaborateurs
chers collègues je vous prie d'abord
d'excuser l'absence du président buffet
que je vais remplacer modestement ce
matin
monsieur le ministre nous vous
accueillons donc aujourd'hui pour cette
audition qui serait inscrit dans dans le
cadre des travaux d'évaluation menés par
notre commission sur cette loi du 23
juillet 2013 relative à la
représentation des Français établit hors
de France 10 ans presque jour pour jour
après la promégation de ce texte nous
rapporteur Christophe André Frassa et
Jean-Yves Lecomte qui était déjà à
porteur de cette loi il y a 10 ans vont
présenter leur rapport je crois que
c'est prévu pour demain ils ont mené
dans le cadre d'une mission
d'information plusieurs auditions pour
déterminer si les dispositifs mis en
place en 2013 s'avère
effectif et surtout garantissent dans
des conditions satisfaisantes la
représentation de nos compatriotes
établir de France lorsque je crois que
cette audition était programmée un petit
peu plus tôt mais qui avait dû être
décalé donc elle a à l'intervient à la
fin de notre processus d'évaluation
c'est l'occasion pour nous de pour vous
de nous présenter à titreliminaire un
panorama de la mise en oeuvre de cette
loi en marquant selon vous ses succès
mais sans éluder bien entendu les
difficultés d'application qui peut se
rencontrer et le cas échéant les voix
d'amélioration et à la suite de votre
propos liminaire monsieur le ministre je
laisserai la parole à nos deux
rapporteurs qui auront des questions à
vous poser et ensuite à nos collègues
qui sont dans la salle qui
souhaiteraient prendre la parole donc je
vous laisse
le micro monsieur le ministre
merci beaucoup madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
d'abord permettez-moi de m'excuser de
n'avoir pu venir avant devant votre
commission voilà mais je suis sûr que
vous comprendrez que c'était pour la
bonne cause puisque ce sont les
déplacements très réguliers pour ne pas
dire incessant que je fais à l'étranger
je dois en être pas loin du 40e pays
depuis ma nomination le 4 juillet
dernier voilà et donc cela me permet
aussi d'être au plus proche de nos
compatriotes les Français de l'étranger
dont l'objectif de la loi du 22 juillet
2013 était bien de renforcer le service
à travers leur représentation
d'abord qu'il ne soit permis ici si vous
me permettez de remercier la sénatrice
Hélène que Noémie Mouret
nous lui devons cette loi lorsqu'elle
était à ma place ministre délégué aux
Français de
en 2013 mais nous la devons aussi à
certains d'entre vous dont les
rapporteurs de cette mission
d'information et cette infrassa et le
compte qui siégeait déjà dans cette
assemblée et qui ont eu à cœur dans
d'améliorer les dispositions dans le
cadre des débats parlementaires je pense
notamment aux améliorations qui ont été
apportées par voie d'amendement dans
deux autres lois celle de 2019 et de
2020 sur lesquels nous d'où reviendrons
je vous disais que j'ai eu la chance le
privilège l'honneur de pouvoir
rencontrer nos compatriotes dans près de
40 pays depuis le début de ma prise de
fonction
avec chaque fois des échanges
privilégiés évidemment avec les
conseillers des Français de l'étranger
j'ai pu en rencontrer un peu plus de 150
depuis un an dans leur pays et ce sont
évidemment des échanges qui m'ont
fortement nourri
ce que j'en retire c'est un premier
constat c'est que les Français de
l'étranger sont dans leur grande
majorité des compatriotes heureux
et passionnés fier de leur parcours de
leur vie de leurs engagements
mais ce sont aussi évidemment des
compatriotes qui ont des attentes et des
exigences fortes vis-à-vis de l'État et
des actions évidemment qu'il engagent à
leur égard
j'ai eu l'occasion lors des deux
dernières sessions
de l'Assemblée des Français de
l'étranger qui a de parler d'amour et de
preuves d'amour
je dis souvent il faut démontrer mais
oui parce que il faut démontrer
à nos compatriotes que même s'ils sont
loin des yeux ils ne sont pas loin du
cœur
voilà donc
après les discours d'amour viennent les
preuves
et les preuves évidemment c'est la
déclinaison de l'ensemble des
engagements que nous avons pris au cours
de ce mandat vis-à-vis de compatriotes
que ce soit la dématérialisation la
dématérisation de l'état civil des
procurations la dématérialisation du
renouvellement des passeports que ce
soit également sous le biais du Pass
Culture ou du passé du question que ce
soit par le vote par internet que ce
soit sur la résidence de repli ou encore
la reconnaissance des entrepreneurs
français de l'étranger si vous voulez ce
sont les différentes
chantiers les différents chantiers sur
lesquels je me suis engagé et je
rajouterais évidemment un chantier
important puisque nous en ferons le
rendu le 3 juillet prochain c'est celui
de la consultation sur l'avenir de
l'enseignement français à l'étranger
avec un réseau extraordinaire de 567
établissements que je visite aussi au
gré de mes déplacements qui offrent des
conditions souvent incroyables à nos
enfants de nos de nos un triote et pas
seulement qui participent aussi au
rayonnement de la France en accueillant
les leads du pays et nous souhaitons
évidemment pouvoir doubler les effectifs
à l'horizon 2030 je rappelle que le
contexte dans lequel on s'inscrit c'est
aussi celui du réarmement du ministère
des Affaires étrangères après 30 années
de Dieppe les moyens sont aujourd'hui à
nouveau à la hausse avec des crédits en
hausse de 20%
d'ici à 2007 pour les porter à 7,9
milliards d'euros et 700 et TP
supplémentaires qui permettent aussi et
nous avons démarré dès cette année le
réarmement de nos consulats pour là
aussi accroître ce service de proximité
qui est évidemment la brique la première
brique sur laquelle l'on place les
services publics pour les Français de
l'étranger alors pour venir au coeur du
sujet la relation évidemment entre les
administrations et les peluche je dois
dire que
la relation de confiance évidemment
entre l'administration et les élus des
Français de l'étranger et crucial
c'est évidemment un lien qui se tisse au
quotidien si vous voulez on peut écrire
ce qu'on veut dans la dans la loi
c'est d'abord le rapport humain qu'il y
a au quotidien entre les élus
l'administration consulaire qui permet
de bâtir cette cette confiance
évidemment la loi a permis de fixer un
cadre
avec évidemment le respect mutuel des
des personnes et des prérogatives de
chacun
dans l'immense majorité des cas je pense
que la complémentarité qui a été établie
prévôt
je n'ai pas rencontré si vous voulez
dans mes différentes missions
de cas où il y avait je sais que on en a
rapporté mais ce là dans les pays dans
lesquels j'étais quelques tensions
effectivement entre les conseillers des
Français d'étrangers et les consuls sur
place mais globalement partout je suis
passé la satisfaction si vous voulez de
part et d'autre
prévaut aujourd'hui à partir du moment
où chacun effectivement est bien dans
ces dans ces compétences
ce qui me semble être une être une bonne
chose
les conseillers des Français de
l'étranger qui préside désormais les
conseils consulaires sont associés très
en amont
et le respect notamment de l'ordre
protocolaire et généralement lui aussi
de cours dans l'ensemble des des
relations des cérémonies etc auxquels
les conseillers sont sont
associés
je m'efforce aussi au niveau qui est le
mien
d'associer les conseillers des Français
de l'étranger notamment
ceux qui siègent à l'Assemblée des
Français de l'étranger j'ai saisi dans
le cadre de l'article 12 de la loi de
2013 l'Assemblée sur des sujets d'ordre
culturel et éducatifs lors de la
dernière session je crois que c'était la
première fois depuis 2013 qu'il était
fait application de cet article voilà
évidemment j'accorde à cette assemblée
qui a
le plus grand respect et surtout un rôle
prééminent dans la conduite des
politiques qui est le mien dans leur
rôle de conseils qui est le leur et je
pense que cette complémentarité ici
entre l'AFE entre la FCE et
le ministère c'est plutôt
bien déroulé ou se déroule plutôt bien
voilà j'ai aussi renforcé la
sollicitation des élus sur des groupes
de travail
et sur des consultations nationales je
me suis engagé pour que les résolutions
adoptées par les fe reçoivent toutes une
réponse les instructions que j'ai
données c'est 100% des consultations et
des recommandations reçoivent une
réponse
j'ai également
fait en sorte que
[Musique]
l'on puisse avoir un dialogue si vous
voulez tout au long de l'année que ce
soit pas simplement sur les sessions
donc nous sommes donné des rendez-vous
hors session notamment avec la
présidente et le bureau de l'AFE pour
faire un suivi des différentes
recommandations et des différentes
recommandations qui sont faites par les
résolutions les recommandations qui sont
faites par
l'Assemblée et je me suis également
engagé je le fais maintenant
systématiquement d'ailleurs
les deux dernières sessions auxquelles
j'ai participé en tant que ministre
à ne pas faire simplement la première
journée de la session on va dire
inaugurale mais je reviens également à
la fin de la session pour consacrer
plusieurs heures d'abord à entendre les
recommandations et les conseils de
l'assemblée et à engager un dialogue sur
celle-ci en disant voilà ce que je
m'engage d'ores et déjà à reprendre à
mon compte et ce qui me semble plus
compliqué en expliquant aussi
pédagogiquement pourquoi est-ce que
certaines choses peuvent paraître
compliquées compte tenu des contrats
propres que nous avons
dans l'ordre des marques d'attention et
de reconnaissance
je me suis aussi engagé à faire évoluer
le régime indemnitaire des
conseillers à l'Assemblée des Français
de l'Étranger
je doute pas qu'on y reviendra mais je
trouvais important que l'on puisse
réévaluer un régime alimentaire qui ne
l'avait pas été
depuis près de dix années alors que les
indemnités des élus locaux comme
nationaux étaient indexés sur le point
fonction publique qui lui avait été révé
l'indemnité des conseillers des Français
de l'étranger n'étant pas
indexés sur le sur le point
forcément elle n'avait pas été
réévaluée et je me suis engagé également
à ce que l'on fasse évoluer la prise en
charge notamment des frais de
déplacement si vous voulez on pourrait y
revenir dans le cœur du du débat mais je
vais laisser un peu plus de temps
évidemment aux questions réponses en ce
qui concerne les élections
partielles notamment législatives
je me félicite que l'on ait pu
essayer de résoudre les différentes
contraintes que nous avons rencontrées
avec le vote par internet là aussi si
vous voulez je pourrais
revenir parce que nous avons eu des
obstacles techniques
importants qui ne dépendent pas de nous
qui ne dépendent pas d'administration
mais qui dépend des opérateurs locaux de
téléphonie dans les différents pays dans
lesquels les circonscriptions sont
situées
et donc nous avons pour essayer de
sécuriser ce vote par internet et
surtout la transmission des codes et
mots de passe aux électeurs mis en place
un système de substitution
qui je pense à donner satisfaction et
qui a permis à la quasi-totalité des
personnes qui se sont retrouvées bloqués
par les problèmes d'opérateurs et bien
de trouver une réponse et de pouvoir
voter voilà
globalement
je pense que la loi du 22 juillet 2013 a
été un succès en tout cas elle a été
plébiscitée si vous voulez à la fois par
les conseillers des Français de
l'étranger et par les conseillers
sigents à l'Assemblée des Français de
l'Étranger
elle est aussi
on va dire saluer par les différents
conçues que j'ai pu rencontrer sur le
terrain qui considère que son
application est aujourd'hui fluide
qu'on pourrait bien sûr apporter encore
quelques améliorations ici et là mais
que globalement ça a permis à la fois
une meilleure représentation des
Français de l'étranger une meilleure
considération de leurs élus et surtout
une plus grande proximité entre nos
compatriotes à l'étranger et leurs élus
les représentants que ce soit sur les
circonscriptions ou à l'Assemblée des
Français de l'étranger et donc je
voudrais évidemment pour cela en
remercier le législateur merci
merci monsieur le ministre pour cette
présentation je vais laisser la parole à
nos deux rapporteurs qui souhaitent
intervenir en premier monsieur fera ça
merci madame la Présidente merci
Monsieur le Ministre
les vrais que on a tous entendu
vos prises de parole depuis vos votre
entrée en fonction et c'est vrai que
votre phrase a fait le tour du monde
c'est qu'à de le dire chez nous sur
l'amour et les preuves d'amour
mais j'y reviendrai plus tard
c'est vrai que 10 ans après son entrée
en vigueur
cette loi a fait ses preuves
elle était saluée et attendue je crois
on peut le dire aujourd'hui sur tous les
bancs et parmi tous les groupes
politiques que ce soit à l'Assemblée au
Sénat puisque nous attendions une
modification d'une part du collège
électoral
pour l'élection des sénateurs et surtout
une plus grande proximité
pour nos compatriotes dans l'exercice du
mandat local de la représentation des
Français étrangers et sur ces deux
points la loi a répondu à ces deux
objectifs
c'est la troisième fois que on fait cet
exercice de bilan nous avions voulu le
faire un an après l'entrée en vigueur
pour tirer un premier enseignement de
l'élection de 2014 et des sénateurs de
2014 sur le plan de la mécanique
électorale et de l'entrée en vigueur des
conseils consulaires
nous avions fait un deuxième exercice
sur ce qui pouvait être amélioré à
l'aune des
élections de 2020 puis reporté à 2021 et
nous voici maintenant sur ce qui peut
être j'allais dire la grande révision
des 10 ans d'application de cette loi
alors c'est vrai que sur l'essentiel
cette loi a bien tenu elle a tenu ses
promesses
nous sommes aujourd'hui avec des élus
qui sont beaucoup plus proches de nos
compatriotes nous nous avons
des conseils consulaires qui on va dire
sur l'ensemble
excusez-moi parce que je sentais quelque
chose qui vivrait mais je sais pas quoi
c'était moi
nous sommes aujourd'hui avec des
conseils consulaires qui sont j'allais
dire vraiment en prise avec le quotidien
des communautés qu'il représente
mais et sur le mécanisme de l'élection
sénatoriale pour je brosse jusqu'au bout
les dispositifs de la loi
ça fonctionne
en 2014 en 2017 en 2021
ça a bien fonctionné puisque
j'allais dire elle se sont déroulées
correctement à chaque fois
il y a quand même un système qui à mon
avis ne nous convainc pas globalement je
veux dire tous c'est le rôle des volumes
à la fe je pense qu'on s'est arrêté au
milieu du gué à mi-chemin
life l'Assemblée des Français l'étranger
n'a pas réussi à trouver dans ce
dispositif sa place et je pense que
c'est dès le départ qu'il y avait un
problème
j'allais dire de conception de la loi de
2013 c'est que sans doute dès 2013 il y
avait une volonté peut-être dans le
gouvernement de l'époque de ne pas
donner sa place à la fe en tout cas de
lui retirer sa place et nous avons
bataillé je veux dire nous-mêmes dans
l'opposition à l'époque
sans doute le rapporteur de l'époque qui
pourra peut-être le dire pour qui pour
que l'Assemblée des Français de
l'Étranger conserve sa place et
sans doute en voulant batailler pour
qu'elle conserve sa place on ne lui a
pas conservé toutes ces attributions et
aujourd'hui l'Assemblée des Français de
l'étranger
n'a pas
toutes ces attributions
je dirais entre les conseils consulaires
qui sont des assemblées locales
et le Parlement qui est l'échelon
national de la représentation des
Français de l'étranger et ce qui
pourrait s'apparenter logiquement à un
conseil régional que pourrait jouer
l'Assemblée des Français l'étranger
manque encore de prérogatifs et c'est là
sans doute si nous devions tirer un
bilan qu'il y a un renforcement des
prérogatives à
mettre en j'allais dire en lumière et
sur lequel nous nous souhaitons faire
des propositions voilà voilà les propos
liminaires que je voulais faire et
dernier point vous parliez de rapport
humain c'est vrai que là aussi peut-être
on est dans un mandat qui repose
beaucoup et à mon sens peut-être
beaucoup trop contrairement
au rapport qui sont peut-être plus
codifiés et peut-être beaucoup plus
rentré dans les mœurs parce que la
tradition est beaucoup plus ancienne
entre les élus locaux et le corps
préfectoral mais c'est vrai que entre le
corps consulaire le corps diplomatique
et les élus consulaires
c'était essentiellement un rapport
humain et là où ça se passe bien ça se
passe très bien mais là où finalement
par j'allais dire par manque de culture
de relation d'un diplomate ou d'un
consul général avec des élus et ça je
pense que c'est uniquement j'allais dire
un travail culturel qu'il faut faire on
pourra améliorer les textes autant qu'on
le veut on pourra mettre autant de
j'allais dire de l'instruction de
circulaire mais peut-être que c'est un
module de préparation qu'il faudrait
prévoir avant j'allais dire des parents
poste peut-être que c'est j'allais dire
quelque chose qui doit se préparer dans
tous les circuits avant qu'un chef de
poste qui soit ambassadeur ou consul
général partent en pour prendre ses
fonctions c'est peut-être ça qu'il faut
prévoir j'allais dire dans tout le
circuit que les futurs chefs de pose
c'est peut-être ça qu'il faut prévoir
c'est-à-dire leur apprendre ce que sont
ces personnages qu'ils vont rencontrer
et que l'on appelle des conseillers des
Français de l'étranger pour leur dire
que ce ne sont pas des adversaires que
ce ne sont pas des empêcheurs de tourner
en rond mais que ce sont à l'instar de
ce que sont les élus locaux sur le
terrain des interlocuteurs quelquefois
des interlocuteurs privilégiés voilà
donc je voulais juste en proposer en
propos liminaire parler de ces quelques
points merci Madame président monsieur
le ministre merci Monsieur François
monsieur Lecomte oui merci madame la
Présidente merci monsieur le ministre
comme le disait Christophe la loi de
2013 qui a mis en place une grande
proximité entre les élus d'une part et
les Français de l'étranger a représenté
un progrès avec la situation précédente
où nous avions moins de 50
circonscriptions et des circonscriptions
qui parfois regroupaient plus de 20 pays
maintenant nous avons 130
circonscriptions 443 élus consulaires et
c'est effectivement un progrès dans la
proximité même si parfois certains
expriment un certain nombre de regrets
justement de cette représentation à deux
niveaux qui convient à certains qui
finalement sont très contents de ne
faire de de faire de l'action locale et
de ne pas aller à Paris mais d'autres
qui considèrent que voilà cette
représentation à deux niveaux est
parfois un peu frustrante et ne met pas
l'ensemble des élus à égalité face à
l'administration à la capacité d'obtenir
des questions d'obtenir des réponses à
leurs questions d'obtenir un soutien
je ferai quelques remarques générales
sur la situation et et les conséquences
de cette loi d'abord sur
en 2001 des grosses avancées de la loi
2013 au delà de cette proximité et des
136 conscriptions c'était l'avoir un
président élu par les membres de
l'Assemblée des Français à l'étranger et
pour avoir été vice-président dans la
phase précédente de l'Assemblée nous
nous appuyons beaucoup sur le ministre
des Affaires étrangères pour finalement
l'ensemble du fonctionnement de cette
assemblée et l'organisation de nos
sessions et le fait est que nous devons
constater que oui maintenant il y a un
président de l'Assemblée des Français à
l'étranger mais les moyens qui sont
dévolus par le ministère des Affaires
étrangères à l'assemblée sont bien
inférieures aujourd'hui à ce qu'ils
étaient à l'époque le secrétariat
général de l'assemblée était le
secrétaire général dédié qui ne faisait
que ça tout au long de l'année et qui
avait un certain nombre
d'administrateurs qui accompagnait
l'ensemble des commissions pour leurs
travaux nous n'avons plus ça nous avons
un secrétariat général qui est réduit à
un minimum avec des personnes qui sont
dedans qui ont d'autres fonctions au
sein de la DFE et la première question
que l'on doit vous poser c'est comment
sortir de cette situation qui finalement
empêche l'Assemblée des Français
d'étrangers d'avoir une activité et de
préparer les sessions tout au long tout
au long de l'année et comment aussi
faire en sorte que cette cette assemblée
puisse avoir un secrétariat général en
propre et qui soit autonome dans la
manière de quelle qu'elle soit autonome
dans la manière de décider d'utiliser
son budget
deuxième
et donc la question est de savoir si
c'est la bonne place et les bons moyens
que nous avons aujourd'hui pour
l'Assemblée des Français à l'étranger
deuxième
série de remarques vous avez évoqué la
question des indemnités nous partageons
votre préoccupation est-ce que vous
considérez compte tenu de ce que vous
voulez faire évoluer que en ce qui
concerne par exemple les élus à
l'Assemblée des défenses et l'étranger
il y a besoin d'une modification
législatives ou est-ce que c'est
simplement de la responsabilité de de
ministère de l'étrangères que de
modifier les choses sachant que la loi
réduit finalement la capacité
d'indemnisation des élus à l'Assemblée
des Français étrangers à des
remboursements de frais mais
certainement pas à des une indemnités
qui serait liée aux responsabilités qui
pourraient avoir localement donc est-ce
que vous avez une un changement
législatif sur le sur ce point autre
remarque sur les conseillers des
Français d'étrangers les
circonscriptions électorales nous avons
pu voir un certain nombre de tensions
parfois ou d'incompréhension lorsque
nous avons des circonscriptions
électorales qui ne sont pas similaires
aux circonscriptions consulaires ou qui
évoluent lorsque les circonscriptions
électorales
regroupent plusieurs circonscriptions
consulaires ou lorsque vous avez des
circonscriptions considères qui ont été
modifiées et qui dépassent les
circonscriptions électorales est-ce que
vous considérez que la situation qui est
ce qui est aujourd'hui dans la loi et la
pratique de la DFE
correspondent à ce qui est souhaité ou
est-ce qu'il faudrait des évolutions et
des évolutions législatives sur ce sur
ce point
voilà pour
cette partie de remarque concernant les
élections
nous avons pu constater un certain
nombre de fois des besoins d'un comité
de propagande nous avons constaté que la
DFE considérait que c'était compliqué et
ça n'était pas mis en œuvre toutefois de
constatons compte tenu de un certain
nombre de publications qui sont
produites par les candidats qu'il serait
utile qui est néanmoins un comité de
propagande est-ce que vous vous pouvez y
être favorable quelques même si nous
comprenons les difficultés qui peut y
avoir à mettre ça en place dans 130
circonscription d'un coup sur les
questions électorales compte tenu des
trois annulations sur 11
circonscriptions l'année dernière pour
les élections législatives est-ce que
vous considérez que la loi actuelle est
satisfaisante en matière de vote
électronique où faudrait-il mettre des
dispositions complémentaires ou est-ce
que tu es c’était simple est-ce que vous
mettez finalement l'ensemble des
adulations sur le dos technique des
prestataires ou est-ce qu'il y a
l'évolution à faire sur le plan
législatif
sur les compétences de la fe qui
évoquaient Christophe nous avons un
certain nombre de points et vous savez
parfaitement les tensions qui peut y
avoir en particulier et les frustrations
qui peut y avoir sur le dispositif de
soutien au tissu associatif français à
l'étranger entre les conseils
consulaires la fe et la DFE et vous en
êtes plusieurs fois témoins est-ce que
vous
seriez favorable à ce que sur ce sujet
mais aussi sur les bourses scolaires ou
sur l'action sociale des compétences
particulières soit donnée en propre ou
en liaison avec les administrations
concernées pour non seulement faire des
propositions mais réellement avoir une
compétence d'attribution est-ce que vous
pensez que finalement dans la ligne de
ce qu'a dit Christophe disons après une
loi qui a fait de la proximité il serait
quand même temps de donner quelques
compétences aux élus sur des sujets qui
sur lequel ils peuvent apporter quelque
chose et enfin puisque
nous nous je voudrais je voudrais
conclure avec quelque chose qui n'est
pas dans la loi mais qui est une
pratique de l'organisation
administrative depuis en fait un petit
peu avant la loi c'est-à-dire
l'existence d'un ministre ou d'un
secrétaire d'État chargé des Français de
l'étranger qui est l'interlocuteur
privilégié des élus défenses et de
l'étranger mais sur lequel nous devons
constater que vous n'avez pas la tutelle
de votre administration vous avez une
administration qui est sous la
responsabilité du mise à faire des
étrangère et qui est mise à votre
disposition pour vos fonctions mais
lorsque vous êtes lorsque vous échangez
avec des élus et que vous voyez que les
questions d'enveloppe de bourse scolaire
d'enveloppes pour relevaloriser compte
tenu de l'hyperinflation dans un certain
nombre de pays les les l'action sociale
lorsque vous vous déplacez en Espagne et
que vous voyez la situation de la MLF
ne regrettez-vous pas finalement de ne
pas avoir directement
sous votre direction une direction des
Français à l'étranger qui pourrait
opérer directement les choses plutôt que
de dépendre du ministre des Affaires
étrangères cette pratique qui existe
depuis plus de 10 ans finalement mais un
espèce de voile entre le ministre qui
est décisionnaire et les élus locaux et
comment est-ce que vous vivez cela
merci Monsieur le Gantois là Monsieur le
Ministre une bonne série de quêtes de
première bonne série de questions je
vous laisse la parole pour répondre
merci merci beaucoup madame la
Présidente
alors d'abord pour répondre à monsieur
le sénateur français je suis entièrement
d'accord avec vous
le vrai sujet c'est ce que je disais en
antenne peut-être de manière un peu
provocante mais on le sait bien moi-même
été parlementaire
on peut écrire ce qu'on veut dans la loi
derrière c'est le rapport humain qui
fait l'application on peut avoir la
meilleure loi du monde si derrière les
gens ne mettent pas la meilleure volonté
du monde à l'application du meilleur
texte du monde
on n'arrivera pas à la solution optimale
et donc c'est bien la raison pour
laquelle
moi je souhaite et je le dis alors
encore une fois j'ai fait une
quarantaine de pays je n'ai pas vu
tous les pays du monde
globalement
quand je discute avec les consuls et
avec les conseillers des Français de
l'étranger j'ai l'impression que les
choses se passent bien en bonne harmonie
il y a des contre-exemples il y a
toujours des conséquences
c'est la raison pour laquelle je partage
votre sentiment que
il faut sensibiliser les consuls au rôle
que qu'occupe les conseillers des
Français de l'étranger et c'est la
raison pour laquelle d'ailleurs lors des
journées consulaires qui se tiennent
d'ailleurs je crois cette semaine à
Paris demain nous faisons ces sessions
de sensibilisation et je crois que
moi-même je m'exprimerai devant les
consuls et je le dis à chaque fois qu'il
est important évidemment de bien traiter
j'étais moi-même élu local et lui de
proximité je le suis d'ailleurs toujours
ça doit faire un peu plus de 22 ans donc
je suis très attaché à la considération
évidemment portée par chacun au rôle
évidemment des gens qui sont élus au
sein de la République par leurs
concitoyens
et je le fais de la même manière
au sein de la fe
je pense que là encore on peut
alors je ne sais pas si
on peut ouvrir le débat si vous voulez
la question
de savoir est-ce qu'on doit donner
à la fe des compétences qu'aujourd'hui
elle n'est pas en gros des conseils des
compétences qui ne soient pas des
compétences
de conseils de résolution de
recommandations
mais des compétences décisionnaires
si on le fait
ça veut dire que
on établit
une étape
une instance intermédiaire et il faut
regarder à quel niveau elle se situe et
sur quelles compétences elle va empiéter
je prends un exemple qui vous concerne
directement
nous avons parfois de la part des élus
de l'AFE des demandes qui relèvent de la
compétence de contrôle non pas
d'information mais de contrôle les
services bon
cette compétence de contrôle est
appartient aux assemblées parlementaires
et à elle seule si vous voulez dans
c'est la Constitution elle-même qui le
définit
ce sont les assemblées parlementaires
qui contrôlent
l'administration bon
qui est responsable devant l'Assemblée
nationale etc enfin bon à travers le
gouvernement
si on donne à l'assemblée des concédés
des Français de l'étranger des
compétences de contrôle alors comment
s'exerce-t-elle par rapport
aux assemblées parlementaires aux
chambres bon
de la même manière
si on lui donne des capacités
décisionnaires
sur
un certain nombre de dossiers alors
comment est-ce que tout ça s'agrège d'un
point de vue juridique avec des
compétences qui peuvent être celles du
gouvernement c'est-à-dire de
l'administration
nous ne sommes pas dans le même schéma
parce que aussi
les représentations des Français de
l'étranger ne sont pas des collectivités
publiques
dans le schéma de l'article 72 qui
permet une dévolution
à travers notamment la décentralisation
ou autre de telles compétences donc ça
ouvre si vous voulez un débat juridique
auquel moi je ne suis pas fermé par
essence mais
voilà qui nécessite quand même
de regarder
voilà sur qui on va aller prendre ses
compétences comment ça peut s'articuler
avec notre logique juridique
constitutionnelle de d'évolution de
compétences
qui aujourd'hui se fait par la
décentralisation la déconcentration
mais avec toujours des pouvoirs qui sont
responsables infinies qui sont contrôlés
dans le cadre de mécanisme
constitutionnel
voilà donc je pense qu'il faut il faut
le regarder de la même manière quand on
parle de la question des indemnités qui
a de l'Assemblée des Français de
l'Étranger moi j'ai dit je veux
réévaluer les indemnités des conseillers
des Français étrangers
le mandat à l'Assemblée des Français
d'étrangers est un mandat bénévole qui
est compensé par la prise en charge des
frais de déplacement d'hébergement de
restauration etc
si j'instaure une indemnité j'ai eu ce
débat avec les membres de l'Assemblée si
j'instore une indemnité propre pour cet
assemblée
je rappelle n'est pas une assemblée
dans le même cadre que celle qu'on
trouve dans l'article 72 la Constitution
c'est une collectivité publique alors
j'ouvre également le débat sur les
assemblées il y a dans lesquels siège
les parlementaires sur les
représentations dans les organisations
internationales l'Assemblée
parlementaire du Conseil de l'Europe
lassant les parlementaires de l'OTAN de
l'OCDE de l'OSCE etc
sur lesquels les mandats sont bénévoles
et donc
voilà ça ouvre un débat pourquoi est-ce
que un élu
qui siège un conseiller des Français de
l'étranger qui siègerait à la fe serait
indemnisé avec une indemnité propre sur
son mandat de la fe en plus de son
mandat de conseiller des Français
d'étrangers alors qu'en parlementaire
qui siège par exemple à l'Assemblée
parlementaire du Conseil de l'Europe
touche pas un euro de plus hormis ses
frais de déplacement de restauration etc
qui sont qui sont pris en charge donc ça
ça ouvre ces questions là en revanche et
je m'y suis engagé aussi
je souhaite actualiser le forfait qui
couvre les déplacements des conseillers
siégeants à la fe la mise en place
également d'un système d'avance parce
que là on a un vrai sujet qui a sur des
gens qui sont obligés de se déplacer
avec en plus l'augmentation des des prix
des billets d'avion lorsqu'ils viennent
de l'autre au bout du monde le prix du
billet d'avion et je parle même pas de
voilà business première ou autre mais
même en économie que le prix du billet
d'avion peut parfois dépasser plusieurs
milliers d'euros bon
aller-retour et donc c'est sur la
trésorerie personnelle des élus pour le
coup que
l'avance doit être faite et ça ça ne me
semble pas correct vis-à-vis des élus
parce que ça peut représenter un
obstacle à l'exercice du mandat des gens
disent ben moi j'ai pas
2000 euros à avancer comme ça pour me
rendre à l'AFE sachant qu'après il faut
souvent avec la production des factures
et autres encore plusieurs semaines
avant que elle ne soit remboursée
voilà et
j'ai ouvert le débat aussi sur la
question de la prise en compte des frais
réels
voilà puisque tout ça ce sont des
forfaits donc il faut qu'on regarde
comment est-ce qu'on peut les prendre en
charge bon sur la question des
circonscriptions électorales monsieur le
secteur Lecomte
objectivement je n'ai pas de
je n'ai pas de d'opinion
trancher là dessus parce que ce problème
n'est jamais remonté
jusqu'à moi en un an personne ne m'a dit
on a des problèmes de surperposition de
circonscription électorale donc je suis
tout à fait prêt à travailler avec avec
vous mais
[Musique]
au moins jusqu'à la au moins jusqu'à la
DFAE parfois même au Conseil d'État mais
il y a eu des difficultés et il y a des
questions qui sont aussi posées lorsque
vous décidez ce qui est de la compétence
de changer
les frontières d'une circonscription
consulaire alors que c'est elle qui
définissent les circonscriptions
électorales oui
oui je
suis prêt à travailler avec ça enfin sur
ce sur ce sujet mais j'ai pas de pour
l'instant j'ai pas été saisi de
problématique ni par les élus sur le
terrain si vous les ni par
l'administration en disant un sujet sur
sur ces circonscriptions électorales en
ce qui concerne les élections les
comités de propagande
l'idée en fait votre idée ce serait
d'avoir un comité de propagande national
national qui
oui parce que déjà toutes les toutes les
professions de foi remontent au
ministère à la DFAE pour être mise en
ligne donc
l'idée était et c'est pas une nouveauté
puisqu'on on l'avait déjà préconisé dans
dans la mission d'information nous
avions mené en 2019-2020 en amont en
amont des élections
consulaires de 2020 donc c'est vraiment
d'avoir cette commission de propagande
qui fasse j'allais dire le un travail
comme celle qui est placé auprès des
préfectures tout à fait avec un
magistrat qui
[Musique]
la problématique si vous voulez c'est
que on a décentralisé les les magistrats
justement auprès des préfectures pour
pouvoir
juger généralement dans une préfecture
d'une dizaine de circonscriptions voilà
bon là ça voudrait dire qu'au niveau
national on aurait 443
pendant
oui sur les 130 circonscriptions 130 oui
ça fait quand même ça fait beaucoup bon
pour 443 élus bon donc il faut il faut
regarder ça
je sais que l'administration
considère que c'est très compliqué à
organiser et que ça peut ralentir du
coup le processus alors que les délais
sont déjà très courts
voilà mais par exemple des élections
mais oui mais enfin j'en suis pas sûr
j'en suis pas sûr parce que d'un point
de vue juridique
d'un point de vue juridique
ayant été moi-même magistrats dans une
vie antérieure si vous voulez là où
elles ont été annulées parce que
quelqu'un se faisait valoir
de d'un soutien qu'il n'avait pas
je ne suis pas certain qu'au niveau de
la commission de propagande le magistrat
soit investi des pouvoirs qui lui
permettent de rejeter
voilà c'est il me semble que l'examen
que nous faisons dans les commissions de
propagande c'est un examen formel
c'est-à-dire que on va regarder si voilà
ce sont les bonnes couleurs le bon
format
etc et
[Musique]
c'est ça l'application du collectoral et
et on ne rentre pas sur le fond de
l'élection c'est des est-ce que un
message peut-être
considéré comme trompeur et a pu
influencer voilà parce que ça c'est
malheureusement
une compétence du juge du fond
qui se fait a posteriori de l'élection
donc si vous voulez je ne suis pas sûr
que ça règle d'un point de vue juridique
les problématiques que l'on que l'on met
sur la sur la table mais je peux
regarder ça
je n'en suis malheureusement pas certain
sur le vote par internet alors je me
permets juste une petite rectification
on a certes du 3 annulations mais deux
seulement sont imputables au vote par
internet la troisième élection
législative a été annulée pour des
questions justement relatives au fond et
non pas à la forme de la de la campagne
en tout cas de l'élection sur les deux
annulations que nous avons eu
je l'ai déjà dit à plusieurs reprises
ce n'est pas l'organisation du système
et ce n'est pas le prestataire lui-même
qui est responsable
la problématique c'est que lorsque l'on
envoie
par SMS le code
qui permet
ensuite avec le
l'identifiant
de rentrer dans le système et de voter
nous dépendons comme si maintenant je
vous envoie un SMS en direct de
l'opérateur téléphonique bon
il y a des pays où les choses
fonctionnent très bien et il y a des
pays parce que le monde est vaste ou
malheureusement nous n'avons pas la même
performance dans l'envoi de nos SMS
alors il y a des choses qui peuvent être
en plus il y a des pays qui peuvent même
bloquer un certain nombre de d'envoies
alors il faut qu'on fasse attention aux
envois en nombre il faut qu'on recalibre
un peu les choses etc mais enfin il y a
des pays où les SMS se perdent ou les
moyens de communication ne sont pas
suffisamment bons nous avons demandé
j'ai demandé d'ailleurs personnellement
à ce qu'on puisse passer par d'autres
systèmes j'ai demandé l'étude notamment
de WhatsApp voilà signal etc et
le problème c'est que l'annecy ne m'a
pas validé ces
processus parce qu'il considère que ce
n'est pas assez sécurisé voilà
et donc voilà j'ai voulu y compris pour
les élections partielles modifier le
système et dire écoutez on va pas
repartir avec les mêmes problématiques
il faut qu'on trouve alors soit on
envoie tout par mail avec deux mails
différents soit on envoie par une
messagerie sécurisée voilà et Dieu sait
que il y en a quand même quelques-unes
sur internet mais les deux moyens ont
été rejetés par l'annecy au titre
justement de la de la sécurité et donc
de la fiabilité du vote
sur ce point monsieur le ministre quand
on a passé à la question ordinaire et
extraordinaire nos interlocuteurs que ce
soit président du bureau de vote
électronique et les prestataires
il y a eu deux
annulations d'élections législatives
pour les motifs liés donc à la
technologie dirons-nous mais quand on
pousse un peu le raisonnement on peut
voir que on aurait pu annuler les 11
circonscriptions parce que le système
n'a pas marché dans l'ensemble des 11
circonscriptions et en fait si nous
avions eu des des mauvais coupscheurs
parmi les électeurs dans les 11
circonscriptions nous aurions pu avoir
les 11 annulations parce que la
troisième annulation elle était sur le
fond mais elle aurait très bien pu aussi
être sur le sur cette forme là et il est
là le souci et j'entends bien les
j'allais dire les récriminations de
lentilles sur les systèmes WhatsApp au
signal mais il arrive un moment où
est-ce que il faut être toujours dans un
couloir de sécurisation
ultra serrée ou est-ce qu'on cherche à
avoir un système qui fonctionne parce
que
WhatsApp bon une fois que les gens de
méta auront vu passer nos codes
pour reprendre une expression qu'ils
utilisent eux-mêmes soit il est là
l'enjeu est-ce que on prend à chaque
fois le risque qu'une partie des
électeurs ne puissent pas avoir
l'ensemble des clés pour voter et être
conforme aux recommandations de
lentilles en tout point où est-ce que on
prend un risque somme toute mesuré
calculer
et permettre à nos compatriotes à
l'étranger d'accéder à un vote dont on
fait cette année les 20 ans de la mise
en pratique aussi puisque c'était en
2003 la première loi que l'on doit notre
ancien collègue Robert delpica d'accès
aux votes électroniques parce que
aujourd'hui le vote électronique n'est
pas un facteur d'encouragement mais on
se rend compte que tout simplement les
Français qui ont prévu d'aller voter
vote par l'électronique et donc il
n'encourage pas à voter plus mais il est
juste un moyen de voter alors quand on
regarde tout de même les chiffres on se
rend compte que la mise en place du vote
électronique est quand même permis
d'accroître les taux de participation
par rapport au vote à l'urne donc c'est
une bonne chose alors pas de 50%
il aurait dû pour la démocratie c'est
toujours ça de gagner et c'est
réconfortant
je partage évidemment votre sentiment
que en matière de cybersécurité
aucun système ne vous donne une garantie
à 100%
je voulais les plus grands spécialistes
aujourd'hui de la cybersécurité
vous disent le la garantie à 100%
n'existe pas pourquoi parce que la
technologie si vous voulez c'est le
combat permanent de l'épée du bouclier
voilà lorsque le bouclier avance l'épée
avance en parallèle et on trouvera
toujours à un moment ou un autre la
possibilité
de mettre une faille dans le système bon
le sujet il est bien juridique puisque
c'est le Conseil constitutionnel qui à
la fin des fins décident
nous avons aujourd'hui tiré des leçons
de la jurisprudence du Conseil
conditionnel le fait qu'il fallait
mettre des solutions de sécurité
parallèles que nous avons mis en place
avec le centre d'appel qui permet pour
toutes les personnes qui n'ont pas reçu
soit de l'identifiant soit le code soit
les deux de pouvoir l'avoir dans les
temps nécessaire pour voter et je
remercie les équipes de la DFE qui l'ont
mis en place et en croire les usagers
cela a très bien fonctionné pour la plus
grande satisfaction de ceux qui ont eu
recours
si j'avais pris le risque sur les
élections législatives partielles de
dire je fais fille de la vie de l'annecy
et je confie à méta en admettant que
j'ai eu le temps de faire les marchés
publics etc nécessaire pour voilà sans
violer dans les délais qui nous étaient
donnés pour organiser les élections nos
propres codes
je ne suis pas sûr que le Conseil
cautionnaire
me n’aurait pas dit en disant bah
attendez
vous avez confié un opérateur
extérieur
en violation d'une enquête ici donc vous
avez introduit un biais de sécurité etc
bon voilà donc je crois qu'il va falloir
peut-être avoir ce discours et ses
discussions avec le juge de l'élection
aussi pour savoir et avec le législateur
pour savoir finalement quelle est la
voilà c'est pour ça que je pose la
question
les aspects techniques tout à fait de
votre discussion du marché public et
après il y a les pratiques il y a les
contraintes législatives et le cadre
législatif qui effectivement peut le cas
échéant évoluer pour tenir compte de
c'est ça de pour éviter qu'on se
retrouve dans une situation d'annulation
si vous voulez là pour avoir été aux
manettes quand il a fallu prendre les
décisions et si vous voulez la première
la première
recommandation qu'on m'a fait c'est de
dire écoutez si vous voulez éviter les
problèmes pas de vote par internet voilà
donc que du vote à l'urne non mais ça
c'est inacceptable on ne peut pas faire
ça on peut pas c'est un retour en
arrière qui ne serait pas compris et qui
engendrerait en plus des baisses de
participation très très forte bon
donc
voilà on m'a dit bah à partir de là vous
avez le choix entre des solutions qui ne
sont pas idéales et il faut choisir la
moins mauvaise
bon voilà choisi la moins mauvaise mais
la moins mauvaise dans le temps elle
peut évoluer elle peut être différente
voilà et je suis ouvert à ce qu'on
puisse avoir
ce dialogue qui encore une fois fait
appel à des considérations techniques
de sécurité dont je ne suis moi-même pas
un spécialiste voilà donc je crois à un
moment ou un autre ce que les
spécialistes du domaine
me disent en essayant de le concilier
avec
l'aspect pratique auquel nos concitoyens
sont en droit évidemment d'attendre la
meilleure solution
un mot sur le staff ainsi que sur les
bourses scolaires
vous avez attiré mon attention en disant
est-ce qu'on pourrait le faire passer
d'une compétence de proposition à une
compétence d'attribution
alors
j'y vois quand même deux sujets
le premier je l'ai dit tout à l'heure
c'est un sujet juridique de compétences
c'est à dire que en gros on
sait pas comment ça pourrait s'appeler
ce ne s'est pas de la
décentralisation une sorte de dévolution
enfin voilà mais je pense que en droit
aujourd'hui
ça n'existe pas voilà
oui mais ça veut dire qu'il faut
reconnaître les Français de l'étranger
enfin les comme une collectivité
publique bon ce qui pour l'instant n'a
pas été le cas et ça nécessiterait
vraisemblablement
de modifier l'article 72 de la
Constitution
donc je pense que ça c'est la première
la première question est non la moindre
la deuxième
il faut regarder alors vous allez dire
la décentralisation montre que ça peut
parfaitement parfaitement marché
mais
quand même les sur des petits montants
petits volumes
[Musique]
comment est-ce qu'on arriverait
à ne pas créer des disparités si vous
voulez entre
différentes circonscriptions consulaires
comment est-ce que je répartis mes 2
millions de d'euros de d'enveloppe staff
est-ce que je répartis le même montant
est-ce que je répartis en prorata du
nombre de personnes vivantes qui n'est
pas nécessairement le même prorata du
nombre d'associations
et ce qui pourrait amener une fine à
écarter des projets fautes de moyens là
où il y en a pour privilégier
d'autres enveloppes sur des projets qui
sont peut-être moins importants
ou en tout cas moins nombreux que sur
d'autres circonscriptions Paris sur les
bourses scolaires et sur les bourses
scolaires ça veut dire qu'il faut que je
décentralise mon budget si je le fais
par circonstances si je donne aux
conseils consulaire la possibilité
de voter
les bourses
voilà donc
je comprends le principe qui part pour
l'élu locales que je fus et que je reste
un principe qui me semble honorable mais
à la fois dans l'application
constitutionnelle juridique et pratique
je ne suis pas sûr qu'on arrive à une
situation qui soit une situation
optimale voilà
et enfin en ce qui concerne la question
de l'administration
de la tutelle de la DFE
d'abord le ministre en charge des
Français de l'étranger est un ministre
délégué
donc il est lui-même sous la tutelle si
vous voulez du ministre là en
l'occurrence de l'Europe et des Affaires
étrangères bon
donc ce principe là
s'oppose là encore une fois
juridiquement à ce qu'il puisse avoir
une autorité hiérarchique directe en
dehors de la de la tutelle
ça si vous voulez c'est sur le principe
du droit
sur le principe politique
je dois dire que depuis ma nomination le
4 juillet dernier je n'ai rencontré
aucune difficulté
d'aucune nature que ce soit
avec ma ministre en l'occurrence madame
Colonna ainsi que son cabinet et nous
avons toujours pris les décisions
lorsqu'elles devaient être prise
ensemble et en bonne intelligence il y a
jamais eu de conflits ou à un moment le
ministre délégué aurait dit moi je
souhaite faire ça et les ministres dire
on ne fait pas ça on va faire autrement
voilà là encore si vous voulez c'est
l'application de ce qu'on disait tout à
l'heure le principe humain des relations
humaines voilà ça marche très bien nous
avons une très bonne relation humaine
voilà et quand il y a des décisions
compliquées à prendre ça a été le cas
notamment sur les questions du vote par
internet ou fallait faire des choix
nous les avons pris ensemble et en bonne
intelligence et de concert voilà de
sorte que votre proposition de dire il
faudrait instituer une tutelle
du ministre
en charge des Français d'étrangers sur
la DFE une tutelle directe qui serait
différent de celle
du ministre de plein d'exercice
pour l'instant ne me semble pas
voilà
pertinente ni sur le plan juridique ni
sur le plan politique
merci Monsieur ministre monsieur fraçage
je pense
on a bientôt terminé donc sans vouloir
rallonger nos débats moi je voulais
juste rebondir sur ce que vous avez dit
monsieur le ministre en faisant tout à
l'heure le parallèle entre les élus de
la fe et les élus des
institutions comme la paix autant la PCE
le see ou la PF
pour siéger dans l'une de celle-ci j'y
suis nommé par
par mes pères et non pas élus ce qui est
la différence des élus de la fe qui sont
élus par leur père pour siéger à la fe
ce qui serait peut-être intéressant
c'est de passer à la
à la proposition qui était celle du
Sénat dans dans sa lecture il y a 10 ans
c'est que les deux élections soient
conjointe et qu'on n'est pas une
élection à double détente comme nous
l'avons aujourd'hui
nous avions eu un petit bras de fer il y
a 10 ans c'était de faire au même moment
c'est-à-dire le même jour l'élection
consulaire dans les conseils consulaires
et l'élection à la fe avec un système de
fléchage comme on a aujourd'hui dans les
métros pour les métropoles etc je pense
que 10 ans après on est tous rodé aux
élections dans les métropoles et que à
part demander un peu plus d'organisation
en amont d'organisation le jour du
dépouillement on pourrait faire cela
mais ça entraîne aussi autre chose
c'est-à-dire que ça entraîne aussi un
peu plus de moyens et là où je peux vous
rejoindre c'est que c'est que le mandat
à la méthode à la métropole c'est à dire
à la fe
entraîne forcément un défraiement
c'est-à-dire dans ce cas-là offrir réel
ce qui serait peut-être mieux que le
défraiement forfaitaire qui a lieu
aujourd'hui mais par contre une
véritable révision
j'allais dire des indemnités de ces
conseillers aujourd'hui parce que pour
prendre deux exemples quand vous êtes
élu des Français de la circonscription
de Téhéran ou de Nairobi deux
circonscriptions qui comportent
plusieurs pays vous n'avez absolument
pas les moyens aujourd'hui d'aller à la
rencontre de vos électeurs quand vous
êtes dans une circonscription qui
recouvre plusieurs pays et c'est pas
avec l'Inde qu'on donne que n'importe
quel élu qui soit le président du
Conseil consulaire ou les autres élus
d'aller tout simplement aux différents
conseils d'établissements auxquels ils
sont régulièrement invités parce que cet
indemnité qui leur est donnée enfin ne
leur permet absolument pas de faire le
moindre des placements donc ça ça
nécessite une véritable revalorisation
de l'indemnité pour accomplir tout
simplement le mandat et là-dessus je là
dessus
je reprends une des casquettes puisque
nous avons tous les deux une autre
casquette qui est celle du membre du
groupe d'études du Sénat sur le statut
et le rôle des élus il y a eu des
propositions faites sur le statut des
élus des Français de l'étranger et dans
les propositions sans les dévoiler vous
les vous les recevrez forcément parmi
les premiers monsieur le ministre mais
que nous ferons dans dans ce bilan je
pense que
un statut des élus nécessiterait une
revalorisation du mandat des conseillers
des Français de l'étranger
pour leur donner les moyens d'exercice
du mandat dans leur circonscriptions
quelles qu'elles soient parce que même
si la circonscription
n'est pas de plusieurs pays et les
quelques fois et je prends les
États-Unis de plusieurs États qui font
pour certaines circonscriptions la
moitié de l'Europe voilà et là aussi il
faut leur donner les moyens d'aller à la
rencontre de
leurs électeurs et de rendre compte de
leur mandat voilà
[Musique]
quels sont vos propositions nous nous
pourrons peut-être en faire sur le plan
législatif mais quels sont vos
propositions pour revenir à une
situation où la fe un secrétaire général
de plein d'exercices et on continue
oui bien sûr merci beaucoup madame la
Présidente alors plusieurs plusieurs
choses d'abord sur
parce que je pense que ça peut être
intégré d'ailleurs à vos à vos
propositions
sur les frais réels sur les frais réels
il faut changer la loi
[Musique]
conseiller des Français de l'étranger en
tout à ce stade et donc il faut que les
élus se saisissent de cette possibilité
moi j'y suis tout à fait favorable on ne
le rappellera jamais assez la démocratie
n'a pas de prix mais elle a un coût
voilà et ce coup il est évident que il
faut le payer voilà
et c'est parfaitement c'est parfaitement
légitime
et voilà je pense que même la question
du statut voilà des des élus on en
discute depuis tellement longtemps y
compris pour le statut des élus locaux
il serait bien qu'un jour nous puissions
aboutir à quelque chose qui soit
formalisé dans un débat tout à fait
transparent avec nos concitoyens mais
lorsqu'on sert la République il est
normal évidemment que l'on soit respecté
et que les frais que l'on engage puisse
être remboursés en ce qui concerne les
élections aussi
je parce que ça c'est on voit aussi qui
peut le qui peut le changer on parlait
des élections qui avaient été annulées à
la suite
sur les élections des conseillers
consulaires
d'une fausse information donnée sur les
sur la propagande en matière de soutien
on pourrait prévoir par exemple des
prêts des peines éligibilité pour les
personnes qui se livreraient à de telles
pratiques ce qui éviterait qu'on soit
obligé de rejouer l'élection que
lorsqu'on rejoue l'élection et bien les
mêmes personnes puissent se représenter
et commettent les mêmes turpitudes qui
avaient conduite à l'annulation de
l'élection précédente il faut bien un
moment ou un autre
voilà mettre un ou là
alors
sur le secrétariat
général
de la fe
bon je pense que tout cela est aussi dû
à la question des moyens internes du
ministère qui n'ont fait que baisser
de ces dernières décennies je m'engage à
ce que l'on puisse regarder les choses
de près avec les ministres
pour voir s'il est possible dans le cas
du réarmement du ministère de consacrer
une personne au secrétaire général de
l'AFE pour faire en sorte que voilà on
est une une gestion on va dire
permanente
du service sachant que nous devons aussi
optimiser les moyens et que donc il faut
regarder par rapport à la charge de
travail que cela induit en temps agent
voilà si la charge est nécessité ou pas
voilà mais en tout cas moi je suis très
attaché à ce que l'assemblée sens à
l'étranger et les moyens de fonctionner
évidemment son secrétariat général et
une pierre angulaire et j'en ai discuté
voilà il y a de cela encore quelques
mois avec la présidente de l'Assemblée
dans quelques mois vous vous assurez que
tout se passera bien que tous les moyens
seront mis qu'il n'y a pas de défaut
électronique
je ne me risquerais jamais il y a à dire
que la chose est garantie à 100% pour
exactement les mêmes raisons que j'ai
énoncé tout à l'heure parce que je pense
que voilà la garantie à 100% n'existe
pas mais je peux vous garantir à 100 %
que nous mettrons toute l'énergie et les
moyens pour faire en sorte que ces
élections se déroulent sans accroc
merci Monsieur le Ministre merci
messieurs les rapporteurs et bonne
journée à vous tous merci beaucoup
madame la Présidente merci beaucoup
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs